- Ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння
квантової інформації та обчислень».
Мене звуть John Watrous, і я є
технічним директором IBM Quantum Education.
Це четвертий урок серії і останній
урок першого розділу серії про основи
квантової інформації.
До цього часу ми говорили про те,
як квантова інформація працює для одиночних і множинних систем, ми розглянули
модель quantum circuit,
і ми спостерігали деякі
фундаментальні обмеження квантової інформації.
На шляху ми
зустріли деякі важливі математичні концепції,
зокрема тензорні добутки та внутрішні добутки, і ми продовжимо
використовувати ці концепції і будемо вводити
нові за потреби.
У цьому уроці ми зосередимося
на трьох фундаментальних важливих прикладах: квантова телепортація, надщільне кодування та гра CHSH,
яка також називається нерівністю CHSH і не завжди описується як гра.
Це не просто випадкові
приклади, покликані проілюструвати, як працює квантова інформація, вони справді є ключовими
частинами фундаменту
квантової інформації і
виникають у різних, а іноді й несподіваних контекстах у квантовій інформації
та обчисленнях.
Заплутаність відіграє ключову роль у всіх трьох цих
прикладах, і саме завдяки заплутаності вони працюють
і є цікавими. Тож цей урок, у певному сенсі, стане нашою першою можливістю
побачити заплутаність у дії
і почати досліджувати, що саме робить заплутаність такою цікавою.
Огляд уроку дуже простий: ми підемо по черзі
через три приклади, які я щойно згадав,
квантова телепортація,
надщільне кодування та гра CHSH.
Ми обговоримо, що це таке і що робить їх цікавими, та проведемо аналіз, який пояснить точно, як вони працюють
на математичному рівні.
Перш ніж перейти до першого
з трьох прикладів, яким є квантова телепортація, варто спочатку
представити персонажів,
Alice і Bob, на випадок якщо ти
з ними не знайомий.
Alice і Bob — це імена,
дані гіпотетичним сутностям або агентам у системах, протоколах, іграх,
і справді будь-якому іншому типу взаємодії, яку ти можеш розглядати, що передбачає обмін інформацією.
Вперше вони з'явилися в
контексті криптографії у 1970-х роках, але
конвенція використовувати ці імена таким чином стала дуже поширеною
у набагато ширшому контексті відтоді. Ідея полягає в тому, що це
дуже поширені імена, принаймні в деяких частинах світу, і вони починаються з літер A та B,
а також зручно
звертатися до Alice і Bob за допомогою займенників «вона» та «він» просто заради стислості.
Зазвичай ми уявляємо, що Alice і Bob знаходяться в різних місцях і мають різні
цілі та різну поведінку
залежно від того, про що ми говоримо.
Наприклад, якщо ми
говоримо про комунікацію, тобто передачу інформації, то можемо вирішити,
що Alice є відправником
а Bob є отримувачем
будь-якої інформації, що передається.
Іноді Alice і Bob
співпрацюють, що є дуже типовим, але іноді вони
конкурують або можуть мати різні цілі, які можуть
бути або не бути сумісними
одна з одною, але все це
має бути чітко описано в конкретній ситуації.
Звичайно, вони є абстракціями, а не обов'язково реальними людьми.
Ми також можемо ввести
додаткових персонажів, таких як Charlie і
Diane, або різні імена, що представляють різні
персони, наприклад Eve
для підслуховувача або Mallory для когось, хто діє зловмисно,
залежно від ситуації.
У будь-якому випадку ми побачимо Alice і Bob у всіх трьох
прикладах, які ми обговоримо в цьому уроці, і час від часу
протягом решти серії. Я також зроблю кілька
коментарів про заплутаність перед тим, як перейти до трьох прикладів.
У другому уроці ми зустріли цей приклад заплутаного стану двох qubit.
Це один із чотирьох станів Bell, і можна сказати, що
цей конкретний стан є архетипним прикладом
заплутаного квантового стану.
Ми також зустріли цей
приклад імовірнісного стану двох бітів.
Він схожий на
заплутаний стан у певному сенсі, але він не є заплутаним,
заплутаність — це унікально
квантове явище,
по суті за визначенням.
Існує точне математичне визначення того, що таке заплутаність, і по суті воно
говорить, що заплутаність —
це некласична квантова кореляція.
Але це не надто
корисно на інтуїтивному рівні, це визначення заплутаності через те, чим вона не є,
і, мабуть, саме тому
дуже важко пояснити, що таке заплутаність і що робить її особливою
в інтуїтивних термінах.
Коли люди намагаються
пояснити, що таке заплутаність, в інтуїтивних термінах, ти
часто чуєш пояснення, які насправді не
розрізняють ці два стани
значущим чином. Ти можеш почути ідею
про те, що якщо виміряти один із двох заплутаних qubit,
то стан іншого
WEBVTT
якимось чином миттєво змінюється, або що стан двох qubit не можна описати окремо
або що два qubit
якось зберігають пам'ять один про одного, або навіть що
вони емоційно прив'язані одне до одного.
Але чому ці властивості
не є правдою для цього стану?
Ці два біти тісно пов'язані, кожен із них має досконалу
пам'ять про інший у буквальному сенсі, але
це не є заплутаним станом.
Що ж, один із способів пояснити, що
робить заплутаність особливою і що робить цей стан
дуже відмінним від того стану, — це пояснити, що ми
можемо робити із заплутаністю
або що ми можемо спостерігати
завдяки заплутаності, що виходить за рамки рішень, які ми приймаємо щодо того, як ми представляємо наші
знання за допомогою векторів.
Усі три приклади,
які ми обговоримо в цьому уроці, мають таку природу, оскільки вони ілюструють
те, що ми можемо робити із заплутаністю, що ми
не можемо робити з цим станом
або з будь-яким класично скорельованим станом.
Справді, дуже типово у вивченні квантової інформації та обчислень розглядати заплутаність як ресурс
за допомогою якого можуть бути
виконані різні завдання.
І коли ми це робимо, ми розглядаємо цей стан як таку, що представляє
одну одиницю заплутаності.
Ми називаємо цю одиницю
заплутаності e-bit, де «e» означає
«заплутаний» або «заплутаність».
Справді, це два qubit, але як кількість
заплутаності — це один e-bit.
Ти також можеш розглядати пару
звичайних класичних бітів у скорельованому
імовірнісному стані, як раніше, як ресурс, що є
одним бітом спільної випадковості.
Це може бути дуже корисним у
криптографії — ділитися випадковим бітом із кимось за умови,
що ніхто більше не знає, що це за біт, щоб він
міг бути використаний як приватний ключ
або як частина приватного ключа, наприклад, для шифрування.
Але в цьому уроці наш фокус буде на цьому заплутаному стані і
тому, що ми можемо з ним робити.
І просто щоб уточнити термінологію, коли ми кажемо, що Alice
і Bob діляться e-bit, ми маємо на увазі, що
Alice має qubit з назвою A,
Bob має qubit з назвою B, і разом пара A, B
знаходиться у стані Phi plus.
Не важливо, які імена
ми вибираємо для двох qubit, звичайно, ми могли б
вибрати різні імена, але протягом цього уроку
ми дотримуватимемося цих імен
заради чіткості. Перший приклад уроку
— це квантова телепортація,
яку надалі ми будемо просто
називати телепортацією заради стислості.
Телепортація — це протокол, що дозволяє відправнику
передавати квантову інформацію одержувачу, використовуючи лише заплутаність
і класичну комунікацію для
виконання цієї передачі.
Це абсолютно не має нічого спільного з типовим тлумаченням
слова «телепортація» у науковій фантастиці, де
матерія зникає
в одному місці і з'являється в іншому.
Квантова телепортація — це просто назва, що має викликати цей образ або метафору, так би мовити.
Те, що телепортується, — це
квантова інформація, а не матерія, і це відбувається
через передачу класичної інформації
разом із заплутаністю.
Щоб точно зрозуміти,
як працює телепортація, корисно спочатку
підготувати сцену, так би мовити.
Ми уявимо сценарій за участю Alice і Bob, і
цей сценарій такий:
Alice має qubit під назвою Q, який вона
хотіла б передати Bob, тобто вона
хоче, щоб Bob тримав у руках
qubit, що знаходиться точно
у тому самому стані, в якому перебуває Q, коли вони починають протокол.
Іншими словами, ми говоримо про фундаментальну проблему
передачі інформації або комунікації.
У нас є відправник на ім'я Alice
і одержувач на ім'я Bob, і Alice хоче надіслати
квантову інформацію у вигляді qubit до Bob.
Однак є обмеження, а саме те, що Alice не
може фізично надіслати Q до Bob, все, що вона може зробити, — це надіслати класичну інформацію до Bob.
Alice і Bob також мають
додатковий ресурс, а саме те, що вони діляться e-bit.
Отже, це і є сценарій, легко
уявити ситуації, де обмеження, що
Alice не може фізично надіслати Q
до Bob, є розумною абстракцією.
Якби Alice і Bob були на
різних континентах, наприклад, або якби Alice не знала
точного місцезнаходження Bob, то фізична відправка qubit
була б, мабуть, досить складною.
Але класична комунікація, звичайно, не лише можлива, а й досить недорога
за таких обставин.
Тепер можна запитати, чи можливо для Alice і Bob виконати це завдання без спільного e-bit.
Іншими словами, чи є
якийсь спосіб передати qubit за допомогою лише класичної
комунікації?
Відповідь — ні, неможливо передати квантову інформацію, використовуючи лише класичну комунікацію, і це не надто складно довести
використовуючи деяку базову
теорію квантової інформації, яку ми побачимо у
третьому розділі серії.
Поки що інтуїтивний
спосіб подумати про це — це подумати про теорему про неклонування.
WEBVTT
Уяви, що є спосіб
надіслати квантову інформацію, використовуючи лише класичну комунікацію,
але класична комунікація
може легко копіюватися і транслюватися, а це означає,
що класична комунікація
може бути транслюватися двом
одержувачам, Bob і Charlie, скажімо.
Якби вони обидва отримали
однакову класичну інформацію від Alice, то
чи обидва вони отримали б Q?
Це означало б, що ми клонували Q, але ми знаємо, що це неможливо.
Просто як відступ, зазначимо,
що цілком можливо описати
вектори квантового стану за допомогою класичної інформації.
Кожен вектор квантового стану,
який ти побачиш у цій серії, описується тобі
за допомогою класичної інформації, яка була передана на будь-який
пристрій, на якому ти дивишся.
Загалом ми могли б уявити
опис будь-якого стану, в якому знаходиться Q, за допомогою класичних бітів,
можливо, з певною точністю,
але це не квантова комунікація, це просто опис
квантових станів як векторів, і ми повернемося до
розрізнення між ними
зовсім скоро.
Повертаючись до сценарію, однак, і працюючи під
припущенням, що Alice і Bob дійсно діляться e-bit, ми побачимо,
що Alice і Bob
мають усе необхідне
для виконання завдання, і саме це робить протокол квантової
телепортації, зокрема використовуючи два біти
класичної комунікації.
Перш ніж вдаватися у
ці деталі, однак, дозвольте мені зробити кілька швидких
зауважень, просто щоб переконатися, що припущення є зрозумілими.
По-перше, ми припускаємо
тут, що стан Q невідомий Alice і
Bob, тож зокрема,
Alice не може надіслати Bob
опис стану Q, оскільки вона загалом його не знає.
Ми також повинні враховувати можливість того, що Q скорельований з іншими системами, включаючи можливість
того, що він заплутаний
з іншими системами, і
передача цього qubit до Bob повинна зберігати ці кореляції.
Нарешті, я згадав
теорему про неклонування, коли говорив про
спробу передавати qubit класично, але
тут є ще один зв'язок
з теоремою про неклонування, а саме те, що якщо Bob
отримує передачу цього qubit Q від Alice,
то у неї його більше немає,
оскільки Q не можна клонувати, і це просто потрібно мати на увазі
розглядаючи протокол телепортації.
Протокол телепортації
може бути описаний досить простим і прямим способом за допомогою діаграми quantum circuit, як ти можеш бачити прямо тут.
Він дещо стилізований тим, що
зображує поділ між частиною Alice і частиною Bob, але в іншому він є просто
діаграмою quantum circuit,
все вище пунктирної
лінії представляє дії Alice, а все нижче
представляє дії Bob.
Час іде зліва направо, як завжди, і ми бачимо, що починаємо
з цими двома qubit тут, що знаходяться у стані Phi plus,
тобто це e-bit
з яким Alice і Bob починають.
Ми можемо поставити мітки на qubit, щоб зрозуміти, який який,
тож це qubit A, а це qubit
B, що утворюють e-bit,
а це qubit Q, який
Alice хоче передати Bob.
Тут ми припускаємо, що
стан цього qubit Q є Psi, але трохи пізніше ми розглянемо можливість
того, що Q заплутаний
з якоюсь іншою системою. І що діаграма стверджує, оскільки ми написали psi тут внизу,
це те, що цей circuit
фактично передає будь-який стан psi, який ми мали
тут вгорі в частині Alice, сюди вниз до частини Bob, єдина комунікація,
що перетинає
лінію між Alice і Bob — це два класичних
біти, представлені цими подвійними лініями тут.
Давайте трохи зменшимо цю
діаграму, щоб мати трохи більше місця, і розглянемо
circuit більш уважно.
Я вже описав
початкові умови, але просто підсумовуючи, Alice тримає qubit A,
а Bob тримає qubit B,
де A і B разом
знаходяться у стані Phi plus, ось що означає ділитися e-bit.
Alice також має цей qubit Q, який вона хоче передати Bob, і ми розглядаємо випадок, коли Q знаходиться в деякому довільному квантовому стані Psi.
Тепер ми нічого не знаємо
про те, як Alice і Bob отримали цей e-bit.
Може бути так, що вони
мали його вже давно, можливо, вони створили його деякий час тому, коли були в одному місці
і зберігали
його для цього випадку, але ці деталі тут не важливі.
Кроки, що відбуваються далі, які представляють
сам протокол телепортації, такі, і просто щоб було зрозуміло,
це кроки, які
діаграма описує, і ми просто
запишемо їх словами, щоб було зрозуміло, що
діаграма виражає.
Alice спочатку виконує
операцію controlled-NOT, де qubit Q, який вона
хоче надіслати до Bob, є керуючим, а
qubit A є цільовим.
Наступним кроком є те, що вона
виконує операцію Hadamard на Q, а потім вимірює
два qubit, що вона тримає,
A і Q, відносно
стандартних базисних вимірювань, і ми дозволяємо малій літері a бути результатом вимірювання qubit A,
WEBVTT
і ми дозволяємо малій літері b бути результатом вимірювання qubit Q.
Alice потім надсилає ці
два класичних біти до Bob, і це єдина комунікація, що залучена в цьому протоколі, і це вказано в діаграмі
тим фактом, що ці два
біти перетинають пунктирну лінію між Alice і Bob,
яку ти можеш вважати таким, що представляє будь-яку
відстань, що їх розділяє.
Після того, як Bob отримує біти
a і b, він робить дві речі.
По-перше, якщо a дорівнює одиниці, то він виконує операцію X,
або, іншими словами, gate NOT на своєму qubit B,
а в іншому випадку, якщо a дорівнює нулю, то він цього не робить.
І подібним чином,
якщо b дорівнює одиниці, то Bob виконує операцію Z,
або Z-gate, або фазовий переворот
також на qubit b, і, як
і раніше, якщо b дорівнює нулю, то він цього не робить.
Все це вказано на рисунку, де ми маємо ці controlled-X
і controlled-Z gate, де керуючими є
два класичних біти.
Тобі не потрібно думати про ці gate як про контрольовані gate,
якщо не хочеш, це просто зручний спосіб
виразити те, що ми хочемо,
у вигляді діаграми circuit. Суть у тому, що Bob застосовує
X-gate до qubit b, якщо a дорівнює одиниці, і
потім застосовує Z-gate
до qubit b, якщо B дорівнює одиниці.
І для зручності пізніше ми можемо явно записати
комбіновану операцію, яку Bob виконує на своєму qubit b,
залежно від класичних
бітів, які надсилає Alice.
Отже, це і є протокол телепортації, він досить простий насправді,
той факт, що він насправді працює, — це інша справа, і хоча аналіз
не такий складний,
ти не повинен відчувати, що тобі чогось бракує, якщо ти не одразу розумієш, чому він працює.
Ось чому нам потрібно
провести аналіз, і саме це ми зробимо далі.
Щоб проаналізувати протокол телепортації, ми будемо проходити через нього крок за кроком, щоб побачити, якими є стани
трьох qubit у різні моменти часу.
Спочатку ми розглянемо
випадок, що верхній qubit знаходиться у стані AlphaZero плюс beta один, де alpha і beta
є будь-якими комплексними числами,
що роблять цей вектор
одиничним вектором.
Це qubit Q, який
Alice намагається передати, але нас не надто хвилює,
як він називається зараз.
Трохи пізніше ми
розглянемо ситуацію, в якій цей qubit є
заплутаним з іншою системою, але це хороша відправна
точка, щоб не ускладнювати речі
і побачити, як аналіз
працює трохи чіткіше.
Якщо ми розглянемо стан
трьох qubit разом тут на початку, ми бачимо,
що цей стан має форму, яку ти бачиш прямо тут.
Перші два qubit знаходяться
у стані Phi plus, третій qubit є верхнім
згідно з конвенцією
впорядкування qubit, яку я
описав у попередньому уроці, тому ми беремо тензорний добуток, щоб отримати стан
трьох qubit разом.
Ми можемо розгорнути цей вираз,
спочатку підставивши визначення стану Phi plus, а потім обчисливши тензорний добуток,
і ми отримуємо стан,
який ти бачиш прямо тут.
До речі, не завжди найкраща
стратегія — повністю розгорнути
такий вектор, загалом це гарна ідея — зачекати, поки
у тебе є вагома причина це зробити.
Але тут у нас є причина, а саме те, що ми хотіли б
обчислити дію цього gate controlled NOT, і записавши стан у цій формі,
ми можемо це зробити дуже легко.
Зокрема, це і є
стан трьох qubit після застосування gate controlled NOT.
Третій qubit є керуючим qubit, тому що він
зверху за нашою конвенцією, а другий qubit,
який є середнім,
є цільовим, тому ми просто
застосовуємо операцію до кетів відповідно, якщо третій біт є
нулем, нічого не відбувається,
а якщо третій біт є одиницею,
тоді ми перевертаємо другий біт.
Потім ми виконуємо gate Hadamard
на третьому qubit, ми можемо записати отриманий
вектор, як ти можеш бачити
прямо тут, підставляючи
стани plus і minus замість станів нуль і один.
І якщо ми хочемо мати достатньо
місця, щоб розгорнути це, нам потрібно буде трохи зменшити
його, і тепер, підставляючи стани
plus і minus
з їх визначеннями,
переносячи корінь з двох у знаменник, ми отримуємо стан, який ти бачиш прямо тут.
І розгорнувши його, ми отримуємо стан, який ти бачиш прямо тут.
Отже, це і є стан трьох qubit після того, як Alice виконує свої дві операції.
Потім Alice вимірює,
і якщо ми хочемо проаналізувати вимірювання, ми виокремлюємо стандартні базисні вектори
для систем, що вимірюються,
так само, як ми говорили в уроці два, і якщо ми робимо це в цьому конкретному випадку, ось що ми отримуємо.
І якщо ти подивишся на цей
вираз мить, він може здатися трохи дивним, тому що тепер здається, що перший qubit,
який є нижнім qubit,
якось залежить від alpha і beta, хоча
на цьому етапі не було жодної комунікації через пунктирну лінію,
WEBVTT
але це лише ілюзія. Пам'ятай, що скаляри вільно переміщуються через тензорні добутки, тому насправді немає жодного сенсу,
в якому alpha і beta
пов'язані з першим qubit.
Все, що ми насправді зробили
тут, — це використали дужки відповідно до
мультилінійності тензорних добутків.
Так чи інакше, це форма, яка нам потрібна, щоб побачити, що робить вимірювання, і ми можемо одразу побачити одну
цікаву річ
а саме те, що ймовірності чотирьох можливих результатів вимірювання завжди рівномірні.
Ймовірність виміряти кожну
пару результатів вимірювання дорівнює одній чверті, тож зокрема,
немає жодної залежності
від alpha і beta.
Ми можемо бачити це в кожному випадку, обчислюючи квадрат евклідової норми
будь-якого вектора, що тензорно добутується зі стандартним базисним
вектором, який ми виокремили,
і в кожному випадку ми маємо одну чверть, яку отримуємо, піднісши до квадрату одну половину, помножену на квадрат модуля alpha
плюс квадрат модуля
beta, що дорівнює одиниці, тому ми отримуємо одну чверть у кожному випадку.
Це досить важливо,
що ймовірності цих різних результатів жодним чином не залежать від qubit, який
Alice хоче передати.
Ми не могли б мати те, що довільний стан надходить тут зверху і виходить внизу, і при цьому вимірювання розкриває
інформацію про цей стан.
Якщо ти хочеш отримати інформацію про довільний квантовий стан, тобі доведеться загалом порушити
цей стан.
Ось таблиця, що описує не лише ймовірності
різних результатів, але й стан
трьох qubit разом,
зумовлений кожним можливим
результатом вимірювання.
Ми отримуємо це шляхом нормалізації векторів, тензорно добутуваних з різними
стандартними базисними станами, але це легко в цьому випадку,
ми просто усуваємо множник одна половина, щоб отримати одиничний вектор.
Отже, те, що ми маємо одразу
після вимірювання Alice, — це те, що Alice має два рівномірних
випадкових біти, і все.
Зокрема, вона більше не
має початкового стану, і у неї немає жодної
інформації про нього, вона просто має випадкові біти.
Стан Bob тепер залежить
від alpha і beta, а також від результатів вимірювання.
Якщо ми на мить уявимо,
що Alice ще не надіслала результати вимірювання,
тому Bob не знає, які результати вимірювання,
то він не зміг би
отримати жодної інформації про alpha і beta
вимірюючи свій qubit.
Ці чотири можливості,
що ми маємо прямо тут, достатньо перемішані, щоб гарантувати, що жодна інформація
про alpha і beta
не може бути отримана
через вимірювання. Це повинно бути правдою на інтуїтивному рівні, тому що інакше у нас була б
комунікація швидше за світло.
Alice, звичайно, не може
передавати інформацію до Bob, нічого не надсилаючи, але звичайно Alice
надсилає результати вимірювання
до Bob, тож давайте розширимо таблицю, щоб побачити, що відбувається, коли
Bob виконує свої операції.
У цьому стовпці тут ми маємо різні операції, які Bob фактично виконує для кожного з можливих
результатів вимірювань,
як ми спостерігали раніше,
і якщо ми пройдемо по одному і застосуємо
операцію до qubit Bob, який є першим, B,
ми побачимо, що ми отримуємо однаковий
результат у всіх чотирьох випадках, і цим результатом є початковий стан.
Отже, початковий стан qubit Q був успішно телепортований до B.
Якщо Bob хоче перейменувати свій qubit і назвати його Q на цьому етапі, він, звичайно, може це зробити, але суть у тому, що тепер
він тримає початковий стан,
що мала Alice, і, звичайно, за необхідністю, Alice більше його не має.
Зверни також увагу, що e-bit
фактично був використаний у цьому процесі,
телепортація має вартість
і вартість становить один e-bit і два класичних біти комунікації, і коли протокол
завершується, e-bit зникає.
Ми тепер встановили, що
протокол телепортації правильно працює за умови, що верхній qubit знаходиться у квантовому стані
вигляду alpha помножений на кет
нуль плюс beta помножений на кет один.
Але що відбувається, якщо
верхній qubit заплутаний з якоюсь іншою системою, наприклад
одним із наших додаткових qubit,
як у нас тут на екрані? Можливо, ми захочемо використати телепортацію
за таких обставин.
Можливо, Alice і Bob насправді
планують виконувати телепортацію 100 разів, щоб Alice могла передати
деякий 100-qubit квантовий регістр
до Bob, по одному qubit за раз.
Або, можливо, ці додаткові
qubit взагалі не знаходяться у власності Alice,
і хтось інший має їх, можливо, Alice навіть
не знає, що вони існують.
Питання полягає в тому, чи
телепортація все ще працює, навіть якщо телепортований qubit є заплутаним з іншою системою?
Тут стан qubit Q разом із додатковою
системою, яку ми розглядаємо, виражений, як ти можеш бачити прямо тут
де gamma zero і
gamma one є одиничними векторами, що представляють квантові стани
цієї додаткової системи.
Ми завжди можемо записати довільний стан об'єднаної системи таким чином.
Насправді нам навіть не
потрібні alpha і beta тут, але якщо ми включимо їх,
то ми можемо взяти gamma zero і gamma one як одиничні вектори
і це зробить
зв'язок із простішим випадком, який ми вже розглянули, більш прозорим.
WEBVTT
Ми можемо провести
схожий аналіз до того, який ми вже провели, але де ми також відстежуємо
цю додаткову систему.
Це трохи складніше, тому що ми маємо додаткову систему, але
ідея точно та сама, ось дуже короткий підсумок.
Це початковий стан, ось стан після
gate controlled NOT,
а ось стан після
операції Hadamard.
Якщо ми розгорнемо ці речі
повністю, ми можемо виразити цей стан так, як ти бачиш прямо тут,
це стан безпосередньо
перед вимірюваннями Alice, і якщо ми пройдемо через
можливості так само, як раніше,
і розглянемо, що
відбувається, коли Bob застосовує будь-яку операцію, яку він повинен застосувати,
то ми виявимо, що справді
правильний стан виходить, і протокол працює так, як очікується.
У цій таблиці, до речі, ми використовуємо літеру R для
позначення цієї додаткової системи, і ти можеш бачити, що ми використовуємо досить простий прийом,
а саме вирішуємо, що ми б надали перевагу, принаймні тимчасово, впорядкуванню
систем як B, R, A, Q
оскільки це зручніше для запису станів прямо тут.
Відповідно до діаграми, системи мають бути
впорядковані як B, A, Q, R,
але поки ми зробимо це чітко, ми можемо вибрати інше
впорядкування, яке є більш зручним.
Коротко кажучи, все, що відбувається в цьому аналізі, —
те саме, що відбувалося в простішому аналізі,
але ми маємо
ці додаткові вектори, gamma zero і gamma one,
що просто рухаються разом.
Ми завжди маємо gamma zero,
коли є множник alpha, і gamma one, коли
є множник beta, і зрештою,
все виходить правильно.
Це насправді зовсім не дивно, ми маємо фізичний процес, що діє як операція тотожності
на qubit
у довільному квантовому стані, і є лише один
спосіб, яким це може відбуватися, а саме те, що операція
є операцією тотожності.
Це трохи простіше пояснити, використовуючи загальну формулювання
квантової інформації, але суть у тому, що за лінійністю,
нам справді не потрібно було проходити через цей додатковий аналіз.
Як тільки ми знаємо, що
телепортація правильно працює для одиночного qubit в ізоляції, ми можемо зробити висновок, що є
лише одна можлива річ,
яка може описати, що робить протокол, а саме те, що він реалізує
операцію тотожності, де qubit надходить прямо тут
і виходить прямо тут, фактично діючи як ідеальний
безшумний квантовий канал.
Лише кілька швидких зауважень
про телепортацію перед тим, як перейти до
другого прикладу уроку, яким є надщільне кодування.
По-перше, я вважаю важливим уточнити, що телепортація є не застосуванням квантової інформації, а протоколом
і зокрема це
протокол для здійснення квантової комунікації.
Щоб телепортація,
як я її описав, була корисною, має бути певна причина для здійснення квантової комунікації.
По-друге, є підстави припускати, що телепортація може колись
стати стандартним способом
передачі квантової інформації, і зокрема процес, відомий як дистиляція заплутаності,
потенційно міг би бути використаний
як спосіб надійної передачі qubit. Якщо Alice і Bob знають, що збираються передавати квантову інформацію, або якщо
у них є потреба передавати
квантову інформацію, то цей процес дистиляції заплутаності
міг би бути використаний для перетворення більшої кількості зашумлених e-bit
у меншу кількість
високоякісних e-bit, які потім можна використовувати для безшумної або майже безшумної телепортації.
Ідея полягає в тому, що процес
дистиляції заплутаності не такий делікатний у певному сенсі, ми могли б прийняти втрати і
якщо це не спрацює,
то ми могли б просто спробувати знову, тоді як реальні qubit, які
ми хотіли б передати, могли б вважатися набагато більш цінними.
Звичайно, це все лише припущення, але суть у тому, що нескладно сформулювати ситуації,
в яких телепортація
могла б бути дуже практичним
способом передачі qubit.
І останнє зауваження
щодо телепортації полягає в тому, що ідея, що лежить в основі телепортації, і спосіб її роботи
є досить фундаментальними
в квантовій інформації та обчисленнях, телепортація є справді наріжним каменем теорії квантової інформації, і варіації
цієї ідеї також часто виникають,
це лише один приклад, існують пропозиції для
реалізації різних quantum gate
за допомогою телепортації, але
де вибираються різні початкові стани та вимірювання, так що результат
полягає у застосуванні вибраної операції
а не у комунікації.
Наступним прикладом є надщільне кодування.
Як і квантова телепортація,
надщільне кодування є протоколом, і те, чого він досягає, є доповнювальним до телепортації.
Тоді як телепортація дозволяє
передати один qubit, використовуючи e-bit і два
класичних біти комунікації,
надщільне кодування дозволяє
передати два класичних біти, використовуючи
e-bit і один qubit квантової комунікації.
Отже, коротко кажучи, надщільне кодування дозволяє передачу
класичної інформації, і причина, чому воно
називається надщільним кодуванням,
WEBVTT
полягає в тому, що воно дозволяє упакувати два
класичних біти комунікації в один qubit,
але нам потрібно витратити
e-bit, щоб досягти цього.
Ось більш точне
пояснення налаштування.
Знову ж таки, ми маємо Alice і Bob, де Alice є відправником
і Bob є одержувачем, і цього разу Alice має два класичних біти,
які вона хоче надіслати до Bob.
Alice може надіслати Bob один qubit, а Alice і Bob діляться
e-bit, що вони можуть використовувати для виконання свого завдання,
яким є отримання Bob
двох класичних бітів.
Тепер є певний сенс, в якому це завдання може здатися менш цікавим, ніж завдання, яке
виконує телепортація,
особливо якщо ми вважаємо,
що відправка qubit значно складніша або більш вимоглива, ніж відправка класичних бітів,
що є досить розумною точкою зору, але це безумовно цікаво, що це можливо.
Одна причина, чому це цікаво,
полягає в тому, що насправді неможливо виконати
це завдання передачі двох класичних бітів інформації
за допомогою одного qubit без
використання e-bit.
Ми знаємо це завдяки відомій теоремі, відомій як теорема Холєво.
Теорема Холєво є
більш загальною, ніж це, і точне формулювання
теореми Холєво є дещо технічним і вимагає деяких пояснень,
але одним із наслідків її
є те, що ти не можеш передати будь-яку кількість класичних
бітів комунікації, використовуючи менше qubit
лише квантової комунікації.
Якщо ти хочеш надійно передати два класичних біти
інформації, використовуючи qubit, і у тебе немає
e-bit для використання,
то тобі доведеться надіслати два qubit, тому вони могли б також просто зберігати біти, які ти хочеш передати.
Ще одна причина, чому надщільне кодування
є цікавим, — це тісний
доповнювальний зв'язок, який воно має з телепортацією, і
ми повернемося до цього
трохи пізніше. Ось опис quantum circuit протоколу надщільного кодування.
Для цього я не
буду перераховувати всі кроки, а замість цього залишимося з описом у вигляді діаграми circuit.
Як ти можеш бачити, ми знову
маємо Alice і Bob, де Alice зверху
і Bob знизу.
Ось e-bit, що
спочатку ділиться між Alice і Bob, що якимось чином було встановлено до запуску протоколу.
Alice має два класичних біти, A і B, які ти можеш бачити тут вгорі,
і через протокол, який описує circuit,
ці два класичних біти
опиняться в руках Bob.
Є лише один qubit,
що перетинає лінію між Alice і Bob, і звичайно, тут не
надсилається жодних класичних бітів,
передача
двох класичних бітів є метою протоколу.
Ти також помітиш, що він має
точно ті самі компоненти, що використовуються в телепортації, ми маємо gate controlled NOT,
gate Hadamard,
і gate Z та X-gate,
контрольовані класичними бітами.
Однак вони розташовані по-іншому, тож перейдімо до
аналізу, щоб побачити, як це працює.
Щоб проаналізувати, як працює надщільне кодування, почнімо з запису
базису Bell, який є дуже важливим
для аналізу.
Ми збираємося спочатку
розглянути ефект, який дії Alice
мають на стан Phi plus, і ми побачимо, що Alice перетворює цей
стан Phi plus в один
із чотирьох станів Bell залежно від бітів,
які вона хоче надіслати.
Тож давайте запишемо таблицю, щоб ми могли
відстежувати, що відбувається.
По-перше, якщо A і B обидва дорівнюють нулю, то ні Z-gate, ні
X-gate не застосовуються, тому дії Alice нічого не роблять,
а це означає, що Phi
plus відображається на Phi plus.
Ми також можемо виразити це як рівняння, яке ти бачиш прямо тут,
нічого не відбувається з qubit Alice і нічого не відбувається з qubit Bob,
а бездіяльність представляється
одиничною матрицею.
Тепер, що відбувається, якщо A дорівнює нулю і B дорівнює одиниці?
Що ж, оскільки B дорівнює одиниці, ми застосовуємо Z-gate і
не застосовуємо X-gate, оскільки A дорівнює нулю,
і ми бачимо, що загальний ефект полягає в тому, що Alice виконує Z-gate.
Alice знаходиться праворуч,
тому що вона зверху, хоча насправді це не
мало б жодного значення в цьому конкретному
випадку, ефект полягає в тому, що
стан Phi plus
відображається на Phi minus, що ти можеш побачити на погляд
з цих виразів, якщо пам'ятаєш, як працює Z-gate.
Отже, ми можемо додати це до нашої таблиці, є ще два випадки, якщо A дорівнює одиниці
і B дорівнює нулю,
то Alice виконує
X-gate, що відображає five Phi у Chi plus, і якщо A дорівнює одиниці
і B дорівнює одиниці,
то Alice виконує Z, потім
X, і ми отримуємо Chi minus.
Отже, наша таблиця розповідає нам, що відбувається у чотирьох можливих випадках, а саме те, що Alice фактично вибирає, який один
WEBVTT
із чотирьох станів Bell вона
хотіла б ділитися з Bob, і вона може вибирати, діючи лише на свій qubit
і це досить цікавий
аспект заплутаності.
Потім Alice надсилає свій qubit
до Bob, на цьому етапі Bob тримає один із чотирьох станів Bell і йому просто потрібно
зрозуміти, який саме,
щоб відновити біти.
І ми можемо перевірити, що
справді gate controlled NOT, за яким іде gate Hadamard,
як у нас є в діаграмі, робить правильну річ.
Я не буду розглядати їх детально, але якщо ти вирішиш це зробити, ти виявиш, що ефект
такий, як ти бачиш тут у таблиці.
Один із способів перевірити це
— просто обчислити. Крім того, ми можемо визнати, що ми насправді вже
пройшли через це у зворотному порядку
в попередньому уроці. У попередньому уроці ми
мали gate Hadamard спочатку і gate controlled NOT другим
і ми бачили, що цей circuit
відображав стандартні базисні стани до станів Bell з неприємним
знаком мінус в одному з випадків.
Коли ми змінюємо порядок gate на зворотний і враховуємо той факт,
що обидва ці два gate є своїми власними оберненими,
ми отримуємо обернений,
і тому те, що ми маємо в цьому
випадку, — це те, що дія йде у протилежному напрямку,
і знак мінус може вибрати, на якій
стороні він хоче бути,
але в іншому він знаходиться там, де має бути, і на цьому етапі одразу зрозуміло, що вимірювання виявляє правильні значення,
знак мінус тут нас не бентежить, тому що один з'являється з
ймовірністю один у цьому випадку, і це весь аналіз.
Коротко кажучи, Alice вибирає стан Bell, а Bob з'ясовує, який саме він є.
Лише кілька коротких зауважень
про надщільне кодування перед тим, як ми рухаємось далі; по-перше, ми повинні визнати, що надщільне кодування
, мабуть, навряд чи
буде корисним або практичним у будь-якому сенсі як засіб передачі класичної інформації.
Класична комунікація
є дуже недорогою, а фізична відправка qubit є складною, м'яко кажучи,
і поки це так, ми б не очікували жодних
практичних переваг від надщільного кодування.
Але те, що воно навряд чи
буде практичним, не означає, що надщільне
кодування не є цікавим.
Насправді воно дуже цікаве, по-перше, основна ідея є
справді досить фундаментальною,
і коли я говорю про основну ідею, я маю на увазі ідею про те, що якщо Alice
ділиться станом Bell з Bob,
то вона може вибрати змінити цей стан на будь-який інший стан Bell, який вона
вибирає, самостійно, їй не потрібна
допомога Bob для цього.
Це конкретний приклад,
що стосується станів Bell, але є більш загальна основна ідея, що стосується свободи, яку має один гравець
для перетворення заплутаного стану, яким він ділиться з іншим гравцем, і точне розуміння цієї свободи
є важливим кроком у розумінні квантової інформації, і ми побачимо точно, як описати цю свободу простими
і елегантними термінами у
третьому розділі серії.
Надщільне кодування також
надає конкретний приклад того, що ти можеш зробити із заплутаністю, а саме дозволити передачу двох класичних
бітів
шляхом відправки одного qubit. Як я вже згадував, це
доведено неможливим за теоремою Холєво без заплутаності.
Ми також можемо розглянути телепортацію і надщільне кодування разом, і ми бачимо, що вони
встановлюють еквівалентність
між одним qubit квантової комунікації та двома бітами класичної комунікації.
Поки ти готовий
витратити один e-bit, ти можеш ефективно
перетворити одне в інше.
Телепортація дозволяє
комунікацію одного qubit, використовуючи два класичних біти комунікації, а надщільне кодування йде у протилежному напрямку
і дозволяє два класичних
біти комунікації, використовуючи один qubit квантової комунікації.
Без витрачення e-bit, однак, ти не можеш перетворити
будь-яке з них в інше, саме заплутаність
робить це можливим.
Третій і останній приклад,
який ми розглянемо в цьому уроці, — це не протокол, а
гра, відома як гра CHSH.
Коли ми говоримо про гру в цьому контексті, ми говоримо не про щось, що призначено для
гри заради задоволення або спорту,
а радше про математичну абстракцію в розумінні теорії ігор, наприклад.
Математичні абстракції ігор дуже широко вивчаються в
економіці та інформатиці, наприклад, і є
значна цінність
в абстракції, тому ігри — це не завжди просто забава,
як виявляється,
хоча думати про них цікаво.
У цьому конкретному випадку те, що ми маємо, — це по суті
розумовий експеримент, що може бути описаний
досить інтуїтивно як гра.
Літери CHSH відносяться до авторів, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony та Richard Holt статті 1969 року,
де цей приклад
був вперше описаний. Вони не описували
його як гру, насправді, і досить поширено
посилатися на цей приклад
не як гру CHSH, а
радше як нерівність CHSH.
Але для такого інформатика, як я, це просто дуже природно
описати це як гру.
Я вже припустив, що
математичні абстракції ігор є важливими і корисними, і існує багато різних
категорій ігор,
WEBVTT
які можна розглядати. Гра CHSH є
прикладом класу ігор, що називаються нелокальними іграми.
Ось загальне налаштування
для нелокальної гри.
У нас є два гравці, Alice і Bob, які співпрацюють як команда, тож вони або виграють разом,
або програють разом.
Це означає, що вони не мають
жодних стимулів діяти егоїстично, тому це по суті протилежна
крайність до ігор із нульовою сумою,
які є суто конкурентними, тут гра є суто кооперативною.
Є третя сутність, яку називають рефері.
Рефері не є гравцем у грі, а радше рефері
веде гру, і насправді, ти можеш думати про специфікацію
конкретного екземпляра
нелокальної гри та специфікацію
рефері як еквівалентних.
Існує критично важливе обмеження, яке накладається на Alice і Bob, а саме те, що після початку гри їм заборонено
спілкуватися один з одним.
Вони можуть заздалегідь домовитися про
будь-яку стратегію, яку вони виберуть, але під час самої гри між ними
жодна комунікація не дозволена.
Якщо тобі подобається, ти можеш уявити,
що гра відбувається у захищеному закладі якогось роду, ніби рефері відіграє
роль детектива
а Alice і Bob є підозрюваними, що знаходяться в різних
кімнатах у поліцейській дільниці, але інший спосіб
подумати про це налаштування
— це те, що Alice і Bob
розділені величезною відстанню і комунікація заборонена, оскільки швидкість світла
не дозволяє комунікацію
відбуватися достатньо швидко. Якщо Alice намагається надіслати
повідомлення до Bob, наприклад, гра закінчиться до того,
як Bob отримає його.
Спосіб, яким
нелокальна гра працює, полягає в тому, що спочатку рефері задає обом
Alice і Bob питання.
Питання Alice позначається X, а питання Bob позначається Y.
Загалом, ти можеш думати про X і Y як про класичні стани
з будь-яких класичних станів, які тобі подобаються, і в
конкретному випадку гри CHSH,
X і Y є бітами.
Alice і Bob повинні потім надати відповіді, відповідь Alice позначається A,
а відповідь Bob позначається B,
і знову ж таки, ці відповіді можна розглядати як класичні стани загалом і, як питання, вони
будуть бітами у грі CHSH.
На цьому етапі
рефері приймає рішення, Alice і Bob або виграють, або програють, залежно від того, чи є
пара відповідей A, B
правильною для
пари питань X, Y, яке рефері задав, і я скажу трохи більше
про це за мить.
Спочатку давайте ближче розглянемо рефері, щоб зрозуміти, що саме є
потенційно складним для Alice і Bob у нелокальній грі.
І що робить
нелокальну гру потенційно складною — це те, що рефері може використовувати випадковість для вибору питань X і Y.
Це означає, що Alice
і Bob мають невизначеність, вони не знають заздалегідь, яке питання їм поставлять, і, мабуть, що важливіше,
вони не знають, яке питання
отримав інший, і ця невизначеність
разом із тим фактом, що вони не можуть спілкуватися,
представляє проблему.
Отже, це схоже на ситуацію, де детектив
допитує двох підозрюваних у різних кімнатах, якщо
підозрювані не знають,
яке питання задали іншому, значно складніше, якщо вони винні, підтримувати свою версію подій.
Тепер, я згадав деякий час тому, що рефері приймає рішення
про те, що Alice і Bob або відповіли
правильно, або неправильно,
залежно від питань,
які їм було задано.
Передбачається, що це
рішення приймається згідно з деяким фіксованим
правилом, і ти можеш розглянути будь-яке правило, яке хочеш,
але яким би воно не було,
передбачається, що Alice
і Bob знають це правило, тому принаймні вони мають
шанс відповісти правильно.
Ми розглянемо
правило для гри CHSH за мить, але ми могли б
розглянути інше правило і мали б інший
приклад нелокальної гри.
Деякі нелокальні ігри є цікавими, і насправді деякі є досить захоплюючими і загадковими досі, а
деякі не такі цікаві,
така вже природа
моделі нелокальних ігор.
Так чи інакше, ось два різних речі, що потрібні для опису рефері; як саме вибираються питання
і які пари відповідей є правильними для кожної можливої пари питань.
Якщо ми маємо опис
цих двох речей, то ми маємо опис для рефері, що фактично описує
екземпляр нелокальної гри.
Тепер давайте розглянемо
гру CHSH конкретно.
Спосіб, яким гра визначена, або, еквівалентно, як визначений рефері, такий:
по-перше, як я вже згадував, питання та відповіді є всі бітами, тому рефері надсилає біт X
до Alice і біт Y до Bob,
і вони кожен відповідають бітом. Alice відповідає A
а Bob відповідає B.
Спосіб, яким рефері вибирає,
які питання задати, є простим, він вибирає
їх рівномірно випадково,
тому пара питань X, Y з рівною ймовірністю може бути будь-якою
з чотирьох можливостей: нуль, нуль; нуль, один;
один, нуль; та один, один.
Нарешті, правило, яке
визначає, які відповіді виграють і які відповіді програють, полягає в тому, що пара відповідей A, B є правильною для пари питань X, Y
WEBVTT
тоді і тільки тоді, коли виключне АБО A і B дорівнює логічному І X і Y.
Це може бути трохи легше засвоїти, якщо ми виразимо ці умови
у вигляді таблиці, як ти бачиш прямо тут.
У першому стовпці ми маємо чотири можливих пари питань, а в другому стовпці ми
маємо умови на A і B,
що потрібні для
того, щоб Alice і Bob виграли.
У перших трьох випадках
І A та Y дорівнює нулю, тому виключне АБО має дорівнювати нулю,
щоб вони виграли,
і це те саме, що казати, що A і B мають бути рівними, тому що A і B є бітами,
а в четвертому випадку,
І X та Y дорівнює
одиниці, тому виключне АБО A і B має дорівнювати одиниці, щоб Alice і Bob виграли,
і це те саме, що
казати, що A і B мають бути різними.
Отже, це гра CHSH, і тепер ми можемо думати про
різні можливі стратегії для Alice і Bob і про те, наскільки добре вони можуть виступити в цій грі.
Почнімо з розгляду
детермінованих стратегій, де відповідь A Alice є функцією від питання X, яке вона отримує,
і так само, відповідь B Bob
є функцією від
питання Y, яке він отримує.
І виявляється, що жодна
детермінована стратегія не може можливо виигрувати щоразу.
Один із способів міркувати про це — просто пройтися по одному через всі можливі
детерміновані стратегії і перевірити, що кожна з них програє
принаймні в одній із чотирьох
можливих пар питань.
Alice і Bob кожен мають
чотири можливих функції для вибору, ми бачили ці
чотири функції в уроці один, тому є 16 можливостей
для перевірки загалом.
Інший спосіб бачити це — подумати про рівняння тут на екрані, ми думаємо
про детерміновані стратегії,
де A і B є функціями
від X і Y відповідно.
Наприклад, A від нуля
представляє відповідь Alice, коли її питання X дорівнює нулю, і A від одиниці представляє відповідь Alice
коли її питання X дорівнює одиниці.
Ось чотири рівняння,
які мають бути правдивими для того, щоб умови виграшу
виконувались у кожному з чотирьох випадків.
Наприклад, якщо X дорівнює
нулю і Y дорівнює нулю, то виключне АБО A
і B має дорівнювати нулю,
тоді як у випадку, коли X дорівнює одиниці і Y дорівнює одиниці,
виключне АБО A і B має дорівнювати одиниці.
Один із способів побачити, що
немає можливості вибрати функції A і B так, щоб
ці рівняння були всі правдивими, — це просто взяти виключне АБО всіх рівнянь.
Виключне АБО будь-якого
двійкового значення з самим собою дорівнює нулю, і тому з цього випливає, що виключне АБО
лівих частин
дорівнює нулю, тому що
ми маємо два екземпляри a нуль, два екземпляри a один,
два екземпляри B нуль
і два екземпляри B один.
Отже, застосовуючи до них всіх виключне АБО,
ми отримуємо кінцеву відповідь нуль, але якщо ми беремо виключне АБО правих частин рівнянь,
ми отримуємо один, а не нуль. Отже, чотири рівняння
не можуть бути всі правдивими, принаймні одне з них має бути хибним,
і це призведе до
програшу для Alice і Bob принаймні в одному з чотирьох випадків.
І тому з цього випливає, що оскільки рефері вибирає питання
рівномірно, ймовірність виграшу для Alice і Bob
з використанням детермінованої стратегії
становить щонайбільше три чверті або 75%.
Той факт, що Alice і Bob можуть виграти з ймовірністю три чверті, насправді досить легко побачити,
якщо Alice і Bob обидва відповідають нуль весь час, наприклад,
вони будуть правими три
рази з чотирьох.
Отже, Alice і Bob не можуть зробити
нічого кращого, ніж виграти 75% часу, використовуючи
детерміновану стратегію.
Але що щодо імовірнісної стратегії?
Що ж, виявляється, що використання
імовірнісної стратегії взагалі не може їм допомогти, тому що кожна
імовірнісна стратегія
може бути альтернативно переглянута
як випадковий вибір детермінованої стратегії, так само як імовірнісні
операції можна розглядати
як випадкові вибори
детермінованих операцій, як ми бачили в першому уроці.
Середнє ніколи не більше
максимуму, тому з цього випливає, що імовірнісна стратегія не пропонує жодних переваг
з точки зору виграшу
порівняно з детермінованою стратегією. Це навіть включає можливість того, що випадкові
вибори Alice і Bob є скорельованими.
Отже, підсумок полягає в тому, що виграш з ймовірністю три чверті є найкращим, що Alice
і Bob можуть можливо зробити, використовуючи будь-яку класичну стратегію,
будь то детерміновану
чи імовірнісну.
Природне питання, яке потрібно поставити на цьому етапі, — це чи можуть Alice і Bob зробити краще, використовуючи квантову стратегію,
і зокрема,
якщо вони діляться заплутаним квантовим станом, який вони могли б підготувати
до початку гри, чи може це їм допомогти?
Відповідь — так, може, і це і є сенс прикладу, і ось чому він такий цікавий.
Тож давайте точно подивимося, як
Alice і Bob можуть зробити краще в цій грі, використовуючи заплутаність.
WEBVTT
Перше, що нам потрібно зробити, — це визначити вектор квантового стану Chi
theta для кожного кута theta, як ти можеш бачити тут на екрані.
Отже, Chi theta дорівнює
косинусу theta помноженому на кет нуль плюс синусу theta помноженому на кет
один, і тут, до речі,
ми думаємо про
кути в радіанах.
Наприклад, ось вектор, який ми отримуємо, коли theta дорівнює pi ділено на
чотири, що є 45 градусами.
Косинус pi ділено на чотири
і синус pi ділено на чотири обидва дорівнюють одному ділено на
квадратний корінь з двох, тому це просто інша
назва для стану plus.
Ось ще один приклад, коли theta дорівнює три рази pi ділено на вісім, і на випадок, якщо ти не
знаєш синус
і косинус трьох разів pi ділено на вісім напам'ять,
ось таблиця синусів і косинусів, які нам
насправді знадобляться
протягом цього прикладу
і включає ті, що потрібні для цього конкретного вектора.
Тепер, якщо ми хочемо взяти внутрішній добуток між будь-якими двома з цих векторів
для кутів, alpha і beta, скажімо, це
просто зробити.
Ми маємо лише дійсні числа
в цих векторах, тому немає комплексних
спряжених про які треба турбуватися, і ми отримуємо добуток косинусів
плюс добуток синусів, і ми можемо використати одну із
так званих формул додавання кутів,
щоб спростити це, це
косинус різниці між кутами, і
оскільки функція косинуса
є симетричною відносно нуля,
насправді не має значення, в якому порядку ми їх беремо.
Якщо ти не маєш цих тригонометричних тотожностей в пам'яті, до речі,
ти не самотній, але тобі не потрібно їх пам'ятати,
ти можеш просто знайти їх. Ця, однак, має сенс,
коли ти думаєш про геометричну інтерпретацію внутрішнього добутку
між дійсними одиничними векторами як косинус кута між ними.
Якщо ми обчислимо внутрішній
добуток тензорного добутку будь-яких двох із цих векторів
зі станом Phi plus, ми отримуємо схожий вираз,
за винятком того, що є квадрат
з двох у знаменнику.
Це перший раз,
коли стан Phi plus з'являється в контексті
цього прикладу, до речі, і ми побачимо точно, чому ми зацікавлені
у цьому конкретному внутрішньому добутку незабаром, але на даний момент давайте
просто зазначимо, що ми отримуємо той самий вираз, що ми мали
для внутрішнього добутку, ділений
на квадратний корінь з двох, тому ми можемо спростити, як раніше.
Далі ми визначимо
унітарну матрицю, U theta, для кожного кута theta,
як ти бачиш прямо тут,
нескладно
перевірити, що це справді є унітарною матрицею.
Ключова річ, яку нам потрібно
визнати, — це те, що вектор si theta є ортогональним до
вектора si theta плюс pi ділено на два, і це має сенс,
тому що якщо ми обертаємося на pi ділено на два, що є 90 градусами, ми
отримуємо ортогональний вектор.
Якщо ми потім множимо U
theta на U theta dagger, ми отримуємо одиничну матрицю.
Інтуїтивно кажучи,
те, що ця матриця робить як операція, — це
відображає si theta на кет нуль і si theta плюс pi два на кет один.
На цьому етапі ми маємо
все необхідне для опису стратегії Alice і Bob.
По-перше, як і для телепортації та надщільного кодування, Alice і Bob почнуть з ділення e-bit.
Alice тримає qubit A,
Bob тримає qubit B, і разом два qubit
знаходяться у стані Phi plus.
Дії Alice такі: вона дивиться на біт X, який
вона отримує від рефері,
і якщо X дорівнює нулю,
вона виконує U нуль на A, що виявляється
тим самим, що нічого не робити, тому що U нуль є одиничною матрицею,
якщо X дорівнює одиниці, з іншого боку, вона застосовує U pi ділено на чотири до A.
Після застосування однієї
з двох операцій, вона вимірює A, використовуючи
стандартне базисне вимірювання, і надсилає будь-який результат,
що вона отримує, до рефері.
Bob робить щось дуже схоже, його qubit, звичайно, називається B, і він отримує Y від
рефері, на відміну від X,
але ключова відмінність полягає в тому,
що він використовує різні кути для своїх унітарних операцій.
Якщо Y дорівнює нулю, він
застосовує U pi ділено на вісім, а якщо Y дорівнює одиниці, він застосовує u мінус pi ділено на вісім.
І ми незабаром побачимо, чому ці вибори кутів є хорошими виборами,
це зовсім не очевидно.
І ось діаграма circuit,
що виражає цю стратегію.
Bob зверху, а Alice
знизу цього разу, ось e-bit, що надходить,
і це унітарні
gate, які Alice і Bob можуть або не можуть застосовувати,
залежно від того, якими є X і Y.
Для цього і цього ми маємо gate, що контролюються або бітом X, або бітом Y,
а для цих двох прямо тут ми маємо те, що виглядає
як контрольовані gate, за винятком того, що коло не заповнене.
І це означає,
що якщо контрольний біт встановлено на нуль, то gate виконується, а якщо контроль встановлено на
одиницю, то нічого не відбувається.
Отже, це просто як
звичайний контрольний gate, за винятком того, що ролі нуля і одиниці для керуючого поміняні місцями.
Отже, фактично, Bob
виконує цей gate прямо тут, якщо Y дорівнює нулю, він
виконує цей gate прямо тут,
WEBVTT
якщо Y дорівнює одиниці, і подібним чином, Alice виконує цей gate прямо
тут, якщо X дорівнює нулю, і цей gate прямо тут,
якщо X дорівнює одиниці.
Отже, це і є стратегія Alice і Bob, і тепер нам просто потрібно
з'ясувати, наскільки добре вона працює.
Для аналізу квантової стратегії, яку я щойно описав, нам
насправді потрібні лише дві речі на цьому етапі: по-перше, унітарна матриця U Theta,
як ти бачиш прямо тут, і
по-друге, ми мали цю формулу.
Нам насправді навіть не потрібне визначення вектора si theta більше, ці два рівняння — все, що нам потрібно.
Є чотири випадки
для розгляду, починаючи з випадку один, а саме X дорівнює
нулю і Y дорівнює нулю.
І якщо ми подивимось назад на стратегію, ми виявимо, що в цьому
випадку Alice виконує U нуль на своєму qubit, а Bob виконує
U pi ділено на вісім на своєму qubit.
Пам'ятай, Alice знизу,
а Bob зверху, тому стан, який вони
отримують, виглядає так.
І розгорнувши це
відповідно до визначення U theta, ми отримуємо цей
вираз, який ти бачиш прямо тут.
Нам не потрібно розгортати
це далі, тому що ми маємо іншу
формулу, що нам допомагає.
І якщо ми застосуємо цю формулу
для кожного з чотирьох доданків, ми отримуємо ось це.
На цьому етапі Alice і Bob обидва вимірюють, і ось таблиця, що
пояснює розподіл результатів.
Ми беремо квадрат модуля коефіцієнтів, щоб отримати ймовірності, що виявляється бути
квадратами коефіцієнтів,
тому що коефіцієнти є
всі дійсними числами в цьому випадку.
Якщо ми використаємо значення синуса і косинуса з попередньої частини уроку
разом із деякими симетріями, ми можемо виразити ці ймовірності,
як ми маємо прямо тут,
в останньому стовпці.
Тепер, про що нам справді важливо,
— це ймовірність того, що вони виграють, і пам'ятай, що у випадку, коли X і Y обидва дорівнюють нулю,
вони виграють, якщо A і B рівні, і програють, якщо A і B не рівні.
Якщо ми обчислимо ці ймовірності, ми виявимо, що ймовірність
того, що A і B рівні, є сумою цього числа і цього числа,
що дорівнює два плюс
корінь з двох, всі ділено на чотири, що становить приблизно 85%.
Ймовірність того, що A і B не рівні, — це два мінус корінь з двох, все ділено на чотири, що, природно, є одиницею мінус величина,
яку ми щойно обчислили, тому
вони виграють з ймовірністю приблизно 85% у цьому випадку.
Є ще три випадки для розгляду, але вони всі дуже схожі на цей,
у випадку, коли X дорівнює
нулю і Y дорівнює одиниці, Bob застосовує U мінус pi ділено на вісім, а не U pi ділено на вісім,
значення у
формулах дещо змінюються, але ми закінчуємо точно
з тими самими ймовірностями, що ми мали в попередньому випадку.
Коли X дорівнює нулю і Y дорівнює одиниці, Alice і Bob виграють,
коли A і B рівні, тому ми маємо точно ту саму ймовірність виграшу,
що й раніше.
У третьому випадку, коли X дорівнює одиниці і Y дорівнює нулю, ми
маємо схожу ситуацію, кути різні,
але вони мають точно
ті самі відносини одне до одного,
і насправді ми отримуємо точно
той самий вектор, що ми отримали в попередньому випадку.
Отже, ймовірності ті самі, і ймовірність виграшу теж.
Останній випадок трохи
інший, як ми могли б очікувати, тому що умова виграшу
відрізняється в цьому випадку.
Коли X і Y обидва дорівнюють одиниці, Alice і Bob виграють, коли
A і B різні.
Основний метод той самий, хоча кути різні, цього разу ми отримуємо цей вектор прямо тут,
і ти можеш перевірити це, пройшовши через необхідні віднімання.
Ймовірності нарешті змінюються, і якщо ми подивимося на значення, які нам потрібні, ми бачимо, що ймовірності фактично
поміняли позиції від попереднього, тому цього разу це ймовірність
того, що A не дорівнює B, є більшою з двох,
але це добре, тому що в цьому випадку Alice і Bob виграють, коли
A і B не рівні.
Тож знову, вони виграють з
ймовірністю приблизно 85%.
Враховуючи, що вони виграють у кожному
випадку з однаковою ймовірністю, що є два плюс корінь з двох,
все ділено на чотири, або приблизно 85%,
це є ймовірність
того, що вони виграють загалом.
Це краще, ніж будь-яка класична стратегія може зробити для цієї гри, і ось що робить це цікавим.
Це виявляється
оптимальною ймовірністю виграшу для будь-якої квантової стратегії, ти
не можеш зробити краще, використовуючи будь-який заплутаний стан.
Цей факт відомий як нерівність Цірельсона, вона названа на честь Boris
Tsirelson, який першим довів її, і, наскільки мені відомо, він був
одним із перших людей,
хто описав цей приклад як гру. Якщо аналіз,
через який ми щойно пройшли, здається трохи загадковим,
можна подумати
про це геометрично, що може бути корисним для
кращого розуміння вибору кутів.
Зокрема, якщо ми використаємо
формулу, яку ти бачиш прямо тут, яку ми можемо легко вивести
з виразів,
що ми вже знайшли для
залучених внутрішніх добутків, то ми можемо альтернативно
виразити ймовірності різних можливих
результатів вимірювань,
WEBVTT
у чотирьох випадках так: по-перше, якщо X, Y дорівнює нуль, нуль, то ось ймовірності
різних результатів вимірювань, і тобі доведеться або подумати назад, або подивитись назад на аналіз,
що ми щойно провели, щоб зробити висновок, використовуючи нашу формулу.
Тут ми можемо бачити
різні вектори станів, намальовані, як і раніше, і колірне кодування тут таке, що синій відповідає
результату нуль, а червоний
відповідає результату один.
Ти можеш бачити, що кут
між синіми векторами і кут між червоними
векторами є відносно малим,
це pi ділено на вісім в обох випадках, тому косинус є відносно великим, і це означає, що ймовірність того, що два результати
є рівними, є відносно великою.
У випадку, коли X, Y дорівнює нуль, один, це схожа ситуація, кути
між векторами, що мають однаковий колір, є малими,
тому ймовірність
рівних результатів знову є відносно великою.
Третій випадок схожий, і в четвертому випадку,
коли X, Y дорівнює один, один, відбувається щось цікаве,
цього разу, саме завдяки тому,
як ці вектори були вибрані, ми бачимо, що кути між
векторами, що мають однаковий колір,
є відносно великими, і зокрема кути є три рази
pi ділено на вісім в обох випадках.
Це означає, що ймовірність
того, що результати вимірювань є рівними, є відносно малою, але це той один випадок,
в якому Alice і Bob виграють,
коли їхні відповіді не збігаються,
тому це те, що нам потрібно.
Ще раз, ось вектори: коли X, Y дорівнює нуль, нуль,
коли X, Y дорівнює нуль, один,
коли X, Y дорівнює один, нуль,
і коли X, Y дорівнює один, один.
І, можливо, цей геометричний
образ корисний для формування деякої інтуїції
щодо того, як ця стратегія працює,
і чому ці різні кути були вибрані саме так.
Щоб завершити урок, я зроблю кілька коротких
зауважень про гру CHSH.
По-перше, як я вже згадував, цей приклад не завжди
описується як гра.
У фізичному спільноті, наприклад, більш поширено, що
цей приклад описується просто як експеримент, а не як гра,
а Alice і Bob
розглядаються як детектори, а не гравці.
Основна ідея такого експерименту, де заплутаність призводить
до статистичних результатів, що не відповідають
жодному класичному опису,
або більш загально будь-якій
теорії, заснованій на так званих локальних прихованих змінних,
належить John Bell, тезки станів Bell,
і тому люди часто називають
такі експерименти тестами Bell.
Іноді люди також
посилаються на теорему Bell, яка може бути сформульована різними способами, але вона по суті говорить,
що квантова механіка
не є сумісною з так званими теоріями локальних прихованих змінних.
Гра CHSH або нерівність, по суті, є дуже гарним і чистим
прикладом тесту Bell,
і ти можеш думати про
цей приклад як про доведення або демонстрацію теореми Bell.
Друге зауваження полягає в тому, що гра CHSH пропонує нам один спосіб експериментально перевірити, що теорія квантової інформації
є точною теорією. Ми насправді можемо налаштовувати експерименти, що реалізують гру CHSH,
включаючи такий вид
стратегії, заснованої на заплутаності, яку я щойно описав, і
перевірити, чи це працює, і це дійсно працює.
Це дає нам
високий ступінь впевненості, що заплутаність є реальною, і на відміну від, можливо,
розпливчастих або поетичних способів,
якими ми намагаємося придумати
для пояснення заплутаності, гра або експеримент CHSH
дає нам конкретний
і перевіряємий спосіб спостереження заплутаності.
Якщо це звучить важливо,
то так і є, і Нобелівська премія з фізики 2022 року
підтверджує саме це.
Премія була присуджена
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, який є «C» у CHSH, та Anton Zeilinger
за експерименти із заплутаними фотонами, що встановили порушення
нерівностей Bell, або, іншими словами, показали, що квантові стратегії
такого типу, який я описав, дійсно працюють і перевершують класичні стратегії.
І якщо тебе цікавить
дізнатися більше про це, я заохочую тебе переглянути
відео про теорему Bell від мого колеги Olivia Lanes,
прямо тут на каналі Qiskit YouTube.
І нарешті, тема
нелокальних ігор більш загально є справді захоплюючою, і це
активна область досліджень,
яка об'єднує
фізику, інформатику та чисту математику, і є ще багато
цікавих питань
про нелокальні ігри, що
залишаються без відповіді досі.
І це кінець четвертого уроку, а також кінець
першого розділу серії про Основи Квантової Інформації.
Перший урок пояснив,
як квантова інформація працює для одиночних систем в ізоляції, а другий урок пояснив, як квантова інформація
працює для множинних систем,
що досить природно виходить із того, як вона працює для одиночних систем.
WEBVTT
Третій урок ввів
модель квантових обчислень у вигляді quantum circuit, а в четвертому уроці ми розглянули три важливих приклади,
що ілюструють речі, які ми
можемо робити із заплутаністю.
На шляху ми побачили деякі дуже важливі математичні концепції,
зокрема тензорні добутки та внутрішні добутки, і ми спостерігали
деякі фундаментальні обмеження
квантової інформації.
Я сподіваюся, що ти приєднаєшся до мене у
наступному розділі серії, який буде присвячений квантовим алгоритмам, де ми зосередимось на питанні
про те, які обчислювальні переваги
пропонує квантова інформація.
До побачення до того часу.